welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
vicky richardson
who recently got promoted to senior
manager
and was the top builder in 2020 for theo
james recruitment
vicky has worked in the industry for
close to 20 years
starting out as a recruiter in 2002
placing office support staff in the
durham area to now
being responsible and managing her own
team and specializing in
engineering and manufacturing across the
uk
vicky thank you for joining me thanks
for having me i i love that introduction
can i just take you with me wherever i
enter a room now
or not i know people don't really like
that because it can share their age but
i think it's something to be proud of
yeah oldest recruiter in town sometimes
so where i want to start is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
yeah it's it's a great question actually
it's something that we've been looking
at really closely
just recently at theo james in terms of
our values and i think that really
resonates when we do come to recruit
for me um whenever we get anybody new to
join the business they kind of spend
some time
with with everybody and they always sort
of ask to give advice and i always say
be your own biggest cheerleader and i
think that
stems from having that belief it's so
important to believe in yourself and
have that confidence
um because as soon as you start
questioning things
i think that's just when certainly in
the early days you can start doubting
everything
um of what you do in the process the
system
will it ever work will it ever click so
that belief for me is
is is huge um somebody with tenacity
again i think is is really essential
you've got to kind of have that winning
mentality um and really sort of go after
it so that that passion and enthusiasm
so
so lots of uh lots of phrases there but
um
yeah so so our values we kind of looked
at and we said belief
unity loyalty and honesty with the four
really key things and i think that
really
does say a lot about um if you're coming
into recruitment you kind of need to
have those values behind you
yeah and what would be interesting to
get your thoughts on vicky is like
how long did it take you to build up
that belief and confidence as
as vicky 2002 being a female
in the recruitment industry typically
obviously dominated by
men what what did how long did it take
to build up that confidence
yeah it did i mean i've got three
brothers
um and a dad who worked and my dad
worked in in sort of
uh finance sales so i've kind of had to
stand up for myself and
have that have a bit of balls about me
if that's the right praise
um but yeah i mean i i spent some time
at durham university i was
i was working in the hr department for
for quite a while so
um working in that public sector to
coming into the cut thrust
cut and thrust of recruitment was was a
huge
learning curve for me um
little little wins um i think you think
right i've got this
i i can do it um but i think i've always
kind of you've got to come in with a
degree of enthusiasm about things
and and then and then that confidence in
builds yeah
it should i just find it interesting
i've had a um
a couple of people on now recent one was
with
gabby who sort of said that early on she
lacked a bit of confidence and
part of that was um there there was a
lack of female role models to look up to
right it was
typically uh guys were at the top of the
the leaderboard
and um also recorded another podcast
with mel who said the same thing and she
sort of flipped that and said right well
i'm going to become that female realm
order right so i'm just interested
on the confidence side because i think
it seems like sometimes that could be
a little longer to cultivate or foster
for
some females because there's no people
to imitate or there's no people
to look up to right or less people to
look up to right so that's why i was
interested
um on that so i was well i was just
going to say i was actually recruited um
in my recruitment career by some really
strong female recruiters um really
inspirational people so
perhaps that's you know i kind of i did
look up to them and thought you know
this is this is the type of person that
i do want to be or you know if they can
do it then there's no reason why i can't
um my eldest was two at the time when i
joined recruitment
so um having having that kind of behind
me to go i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do this and i'm gonna make i'm
gonna make georgia proud it was kind of
like
that was kind of my mentality the way i
went into it anyway
yeah i love that so vicky what what's
made you stay in the industry for so
long
i i just i i it's a bit cheesy and my
husband
who comes in and moans about his job
still can't believe that i actually
still really love it
and and i genuinely do i love how it's
so varied
um i love that i can i can make make
some good money
um and i'm still really really
passionate about
it and i think you know we speak to so
many people every day that they're
unhappy in their job and we're
trying to find them something new and um
you know that's when then that's when i
would leave but i've never
i've never you get bad deers but i've
never been at that point i still
absolutely love what i do
i love that that's awesome and that
that's that's what we're striving for in
life right just to
enjoy what we do so yeah i absolutely
love that and that definitely
comes through whenever i've spoken to
you i guess the
the sort of final thing on ours here and
then we'll sort of start breaking down
your journey and these things but what
came up for me when i was preparing for
this vicky you've been in the industry
for a long time
um and what i wanted to ask you was like
how has
you ensured that vicky has stayed
current right and not
become complacent in your career because
i think that's
sometimes even more so if you look at um
this recruitment landscape over the last
couple of years it has changed
and i think it would be very easy for
someone with your experience and what
you have behind you
to be like i know what i need to do that
works right and be
less open-minded to potentially be more
current or look at
could i change this or whatever right so
i guess what what have you ensured
that you've done yourself to make sure
you stay current and you don't become
complacent
yeah um i think i'll put my hands up and
say
up until four four and a half years ago
i was very much in that category you
know i got
um 14 years recruitment experience
behind me
left alone to just get on with it um
and uh yeah perhaps fell into that
category where you know i've learned
what i need to learn i wasn't really
pushed at all to do anything about
personal development or
um you know being on on on social media
and the personal branding element of it
and it wasn't until
um mark for me um mark brattnell who
who's our directors
is a is a huge part of my journey in
terms of
of that so we've um we've had external
trainers into the business that's really
kind of helped me and put me out of my
comfort zone to say
you know you don't know everything
there's different ways of doing it and
actually
um you know let's approach it in a
different way because it might just help
and
i've really embraced that um the the
person brandon on social media
when mark first mentioned about doing
videos
i was absolutely dreading it and they
were so stifled at the beginning i don't
even think i smiled
um i was really nervous about was a
completely different way of working i
was thinking
you know how on earth am i going to get
to do this and um
this journey this part of my recruitment
journey i've i've
really enjoyed and really begun to
become to love it again um you know i
i'd spent a bit of time recruiting in a
different sector and
it's kind of it was just quite
monotonous but um
you know this this part of my journey is
really elevated i would say in terms of
um pushing myself out of that comfort
zone and saying
you know there are new things you can
learn and and there's things that you
can be doing
doing differently and better yeah now
good on you for that so i guess so
besides
i guess the the question on this or ask
you is like so clearly
people and environment has sort of
really encouraged you to get out your
comfort zone and look at
the way of doing things etc so i guess
we can think about it if you
if someone's listening right now and
they might be an environment that
they've been in for a while and there
isn't any sort of external things that
could push them maybe at their comfort
zone or consider to do things
differently or
if you could go back and speak to vicky
and putting the environment and people
aside like
what would you communicate to those
people that may
be very prone to being complacent and
maybe less open to
gaining potential marginal gains or even
bigger gains right that could
take their performance or billings that
bit extra
length right so what would you say to
yourself or what would you say to anyone
listening that
might that might have been in that same
camp that you was before you went to
fear james
yeah absolutely i think you know you
bang on i think as well
it's looking how recruitment's changed
um
from when i did start and you know
you've you've got to keep yourself
current you know
how i recruit is so so different to to
what i'm doing now
um the fundamentals are the same but the
the extras that we can offer to clients
is
is is um for us that really elevates
uh our our their experience and and what
we can offer
um so what i would the advice that i
would give is is
um you can't you can't sit still you
know
you you know you should never you should
always be be learning
um you know the experience that you've
got under your belt
there shouldn't be a number on there you
should constantly want to develop
yourself for you and like you said
get those marginal gains from um
securing that client that you've been
wanting or
um that you thought you would never win
over you actually can do that
but you know it might be that you need a
bit of help now and again
and not being and not being frightened
of of saying
um i'm i'm struggling and i need a bit
of help because you know whether you're
you know directors managers that you
know there's always some i think
something that they can learn or
somebody that can learn from
yeah i think what's massively changed
from when i um
started this podcast is like there's
just way more resources out there now
like i think the first part is
like having the humility to be like well
just not having the mindset of like i've
completed recruitment
yeah did you go what i mean and like
yeah like you said being open and
actually
if you can get if you can take that step
and then be curious there's actually way
more resources out there now for you to
for for things to challenge your way of
thinking and um
yeah potentially find out different
things that could help you um
okay so how how would you how would you
describe your first year in recruitment
um i was thinking back about this and
i don't i'm not afraid to say it was a
bit of a whirlwind
i felt i felt like i was i didn't know
if it was arthur or martha i was just
all over the place um loads to learn
as i said i i was at durham university
for four years
public sector i had pauline make
my tea twice a day the little little
milk trolley and
it was just it was flexi time it was
just it was an
easy job and it was great and and it
great it gave me some exposure to
the working life after university but um
getting into the public sector and then
getting into recruitment is a whole new
ball game
so there was just so much to learn and
um my first role at his
um it was a hundred mile an hour again
as i said
my eldest was very very young at the
time so you know i was i was just
wanting to be a a good mom and
and and also um really hit this new job
with
you know with a real bang so um put that
pressure on myself that you know it's it
this
has to work out this is what i really
want to do um
so yeah and all really bit of a
whirlwind but um i do remember there was
a call that i'd put into a client to do
some aftercare i was doing some
uh the the roles that i was recruiting
for were temporary office support roles
um and i remember speaking to a client
sort of um asking how that that
particular person was getting on but but
then following on with a
um is there anything else that we can
help you with
i've actually interviewed somebody quite
similar and i remember my manager at the
time saying
um you know how how did you know to say
that and um
it it kind of was was natural for me to
to engage and and have those
conversations so
you know that was that was a great
confidence boost for me but
working in his there were so many people
around me that i could learn from and
listen from
i would just want to take it all in um
so yeah
it was all a bit of a whirlwind but but
i think i hit
hit it quite successfully and and
definitely got the bug from there
i love that so i've got two things for
you
what was what was the best piece of
advice that you
received in early days of vicky's
recruitment career
that stuck with you that really
resonated and helped you
yeah i i don't remember any advice
particularly
my two very good friends have worked in
recruitment once actually got her own
her own business and the way that they
went about things
um taken accountability and i often
heard them speaking to people
outside of of working hours and just
seeing
how they worked as i said from from
somebody that was doing flexi time you
know they clocked off at five o'clock
and didn't ever have any calls after
that
it was such a different world so um
i think for me i learned a lot from from
from my two very close friends that uh
um that really got me into wanting to
get into recruitment initially
so accountability and usually yeah
changing the mindset
of um yeah five o'clock let's clock off
yeah okay then the only other thing i i
get messages about this every now and
again like and there's pros and cons but
like how
obviously you've been in the industry
for a while now and thinking of people
that
you potentially have uh interviewed for
james now and stuff like
what would you how what would you say to
people who are considering
working for uh yeah a company a big
business like hayes
compared to a growing organization
um more of a startup field small and
smaller of size like theo james like
what would your advice be to someone
that's considering um
entering the recruitment world like what
would you say to them
um yeah i think it it depends on on
on you your motivation or your driver
really so a big business that hayes and
brook street
were fantastic for me and um you know
learned so much from
from there so the training that they
gave um you know
actual training academies that i had to
go to to edinburgh or ought to lose into
and learn from learn from these um
sort of take yourself off off your your
desk and go on and do some specific
training and take that time out to learn
specifically
um i mean as i said they were great but
for me i think what i love about working
for an owner managed business is
the work that you're doing really does
have an impact on the bottom line your
directors are seeing straight away how
you're working
um i used to get um emails from
directors from brook street that said oh
you've had a great quarter fantastic
well done you're on the leaderboard
but actually they hadn't seen um the
days where maybe had somebody who
who dropped out or who didn't go for an
interview and i had to work really hard
to
to backfill those and um yeah that's
kind of that that's what i like i like
and also being part of a business where
you can have an impact in terms of
making decisions
um you i think you get exposure to quite
a lot of different things
working for another managed business for
sure
yeah i think especially when yeah you're
you're in an industry where you really
are putting in the work
and um yeah being able to actually see
how that impacts the business
if that's helping it grow if that's
whatever i think that's what i
definitely personally really enjoyed
about working in a smaller
owned um business and recruitment
business i that was definitely what
drew me to it um so what i wanted to
sort of focus on then vicky was so
obviously yeah i worked at brook street
for a couple of years
and then joined another company that you
worked for for 10 years and then for the
last
four years and i bet you've been at theo
james
so from what i can see in your last two
positions where you you spent the most
time
you have always managed to accelerate
your recruitment career
right so if that's taking yourself from
consultant to manager or
senior um etc so i guess where i wanted
to start is like why
why do you think you managed to achieve
that why did you why do you think that
you managed to
push your career on like that instead of
your colleagues
yeah and for me um i always give
everything i always jump in to or i'm
all in i go in with um i think i always
have a
that air of enthusiasm about things um
you know as i said mark will
approach me about different ideas and go
yeah yeah yeah let's do it
um and and kind of just trust him
uh that he's you know these decisions
are for the better
so i always give it 100 i think i work
really hard
um i i just buy into it and then
um doing doing the best that i can
really i mean
in terms of um my journey at core people
and and that promotion there was very
much about
um it was about being recognized um
you know so so all of that work you know
it didn't go unnoticed i worked closely
with with the senior management team and
and they obviously saw something
um at theo james we've actually just
rolled out a specific pathway for our
consultants to achieve
um because i think sometimes people
don't necessarily know what they need to
do to
to get that promotion so that's
something that we've really concentrated
and worked hard in
sort of not not just looking at the
numbers but also looking at the
competency
competencies behind that so what traits
do you need to be demonstrating for you
to be considered for promotion
um even before you're actually doing it
so
um yeah it's just given it giving it my
all
working hard um and not really
not really sort of putting my name up
saying you know what about me for
promotion i kind of just got on with it
and and did what needed to be done and
as i said at core people it was
recognized and then
um theo james again i
you know i work alongside mark very very
closely
um and you know i'll i'll make sure that
i'm
i'm giving that bit extra um but but not
it's not forced it's just something that
i genuinely want to do anyway
okay so had you so
as your sort of career progressed then
had you always wanted to go into
management
probably not at the beginning um it was
it's it's it's one of those ones where
you know
you know it's going to take quite a bit
of time is it going to affect my
billings
um quite a selfish recruiter just
wanting to
to just um embody myself in the work and
and and have that little business like
everybody says
um but now that i'm in it i i i
absolutely love it i think there's
there's just that extra bit of reward
that you get
um you know where your praise and people
you've got a team of people around you
um and i love seeing them succeed
because um you know i'd like to think
that
you know i've got i've taken a little
bit of a part in in helping them towards
that
i would say at the beginning um it's
very much a learning curve i've never
had any specific management training
um you know mark and previous managers
have sort of said you know just
just let them follow you and that's all
well and good but sometimes
you know you've i think you've you've
still got to to um
you've still got to spend that time with
the person if some
we've had a lot of people where they've
had no recruitment experience at all and
there's just so much to learn
and i really want to give people a fair
shot a fair shot at it so
um i'm i'm forcing myself to to really
take time out of my day to
make sure that they're set up um they've
got
if they've got any questions i'm there
to answer them at the very beginning
stages
um i think previously there's been um
i would say i've maybe approached it
differently i think i've
i set very high standards and i just
expect people to to work towards that
but i i listened to
a podcast where i think you made a valid
point that there isn't another vicki
richardson there that you know that
they're individuals so
um you know that really resonated with
me that you know you
i think as well when i reflected you can
take a horse to water but you can't make
it drink and
and our maybe wanted it more than they
wanted it for themselves which
you know just was never going to work
that way so i've kind of
eased off the gas a little bit and not
being like oh you know that that job
title needs to have capital letters or
whatever
or you know you've got to bring that
client straight back it's really just
letting them find their own style of
things of doing it but also
really trying to um just being there as
a support
um there's processes that
we do so um i would always check in on
them
before half eight and i always check in
on them at lunchtime just to see how the
day's gone
and at the end of the day not too long
but just touching touching base and if i
hear a good call then i'll always give
them praise and
um you know i i love that part of the
job where it's that coaching and
development
and seeing them you know hitting their
targets and stuff that
there is a it's a great feeling so what
what would be
so if i'm listening right now i might i
might be sort of early on that sort of
uh leader trajectory and and sort of
learning as i go like you said it's
um you haven't sort of didn't receive
any sort of formal training i think a
lot of people can relate to that
so i guess what would be your like i
don't know three best bits of advice for
someone that
is sort of early on on that leadership
career still billing still responsible
for their own billings
but now responsible for a team that's
growing and they've got to get the most
out of them
like knowing what you know now and the
clearly things that you've improved on
like what would you
what would be your free bits of advice
for those people
i would say um make them aware of your
expectations early on
you know explain to them how you work um
whether that is
um you know that you um there's a
a degree of time where there's that
training um
and that you know you're there as a
support um
secondly i would always say to take time
out
um to make sure that they're not sort of
suffering in silence because some people
are
they they are you know as much as people
will say you know ask any questions
you know no questions too silly i think
there's been instances where people
maybe haven't put their hand up and
they've kind of
they've been they've been uh suffering a
little bit so
make sure you do spend some time and
make sure that they are okay
and third of all thirdly i would say um
take them outside of the business um you
know find out what their motivators are
find out what their whys are
um let them talk in an open forum if you
like that they're not in the office and
you know where
people are listening to what they're
saying letting them have that time to
talk really we do
um walking wednesdays so we have a just
to walk around the block on a lunch time
and
just let people um
express their frustrations maybe uh if
there's anything that they need
a free space for them to talk about
which isn't just like
yeah vika i've sent out this many cvs
this week or whatever right just a bit
of free space to
yeah i love that because you can pick up
on different things and you've got them
in a different environment
yeah and can pick up on different things
we do um
we do consistently monthly reviews there
isn't a month ago by that
that i don't sit with them to reflect
and review on the month and talk about a
plan for the coming months
um and and i think having that structure
as well really benefits
them and me as well so that you know i'm
doing my thing but at
the same time i still want to make sure
that i'm supporting them and um offering
that advice
um but it's difficult you know to to
make sure that you
you're still consistently billing on
your side of things you know i've got
targets to meet as well
um and and trying to get that balance of
making sure that they've got the help
that they need
but it does it's it's just short-term
pain for long-term gain i think
um it's conscience consciously making
that decision to spend that time because
it will pay off if you believe in those
if that you believe in those consultants
and you obviously do because you've
recruited them
then um take the time to spend them or
make the decision that they're not
they're not going to fit in
and you know make decisions from there
but um
yeah the team that i've got right now
are fantastic
really really good so she's a couple
more things on
leadership and then i'd love to sort of
um just get your thoughts
on um just your experience around client
development and and things like that
so firstly um one of the things i wanted
to ask you is a question that i got sent
through was just like
how has vicky developed her
communication skills
as a leader and how is that and i'm sure
you've had to sort of change and
change those during this period as well
so i guess how have you developed your
communication skills as a leader um
i would say they have changed um
i definitely take take a step
back or take a moment before i
react um as i said i've got quite high
standards and i need to appreciate that
people are going through a learning
curve and you know then they're not
automatically gonna
either know the answer or um approach
things in the way that i would they've
they've got to find their own style so
um perhaps
being less jump
jump on them with a with a reaction but
right
um i i definitely think i approach
things in a different way
um um i would say more karma i don't
think i'm
too aggressive but there's been times
where maybe i've reacted
in a different way than what i should
have done um
but again i you know it's it i've
definitely gone through a learning curve
for sure
so it's that whole thing isn't it so
what you're saying there is like you've
developed
your communication skills by giving
yourself space to
think or process before you react it's
that whole thing sometimes you know when
we've all been in that situation where
the client has just done
done us over or done something that is
just not
fair play and you've written that email
straight away you're about to send
sending like
[ __ ] right maybe i should wait maybe i
should sleep on it before i send that
email do you know what i mean so
it seems like that's helped you then
become better at deciding how you
communicate
yeah definitely and and also putting
myself in their shoes is a big thing for
me
um you know not everybody's
worked in recruitment for a lot they
don't know you know
that they are learning and it's just
just having that appreciation before
i then respond um
and and and that for me has been a big
win you know i think i'm i'm definitely
a more effective manager
i think people respond much better to
that way as i said it was never
too much but i might i might just pick
up on things that maybe just don't need
picking up on
um don't sweat the small stuff is
something i've definitely learned
um and then just the the final thing
really
is because because i if i look at sort
of um
mark and you guys you guys seem like
really sort of quite open and
transparent as a business
um and what i just wanted to ask you is
like how have you also
gone about getting better at sort of
recognizing
um people in your team people that you
managed who may be struggling mentally
or just having their own personal
struggles right i think even more so
again
during this period that's something that
managers have had to try and work out
and get better at and
can can be made more difficult if you're
doing it for a screen
so i guess um what's been your journey
with like yeah just
helping or noticing as a manager any of
your team that
may be struggling mentally if that's
with personal things or just finding the
the job really difficult and
sort of get better at that what's been
your journey that i've done if anything
um has helped you on that journey or
worth sharing for people yeah um
you know the culture for the culture
that we've got at theo james uh
for me i've not worked in a better
culture i think it's it's been great
obviously i'm biased we do have a group
what's up that we're constantly
messaging um about
um i don't know jobs that we've seen or
um candidates that perhaps can cross
over into a different
area and sharing that information so
that's that's
constantly on the go um
they'll be you know there's often
occasions on an evening where i'll i'll
message somebody that i've seen maybe
he's a bit quiet on the day or
you know just to see how they are um and
i think that's really important you know
we
we are like we are like a family you
know we spend so much time
uh you know at work we're all very
different personalities and
but it does work really well um and you
know if i can offer a support where
you just want to rant or you know you
perhaps struggling a little bit then
i am here if you don't want to talk
that's fine but i have noticed and
um you know you know i'm here kind of
thing um and i
that's something that i think is
important to do um
just make them feel a little bit like
you know somebody's noticing
and and that there's there there's
there's help there if they need it
so i said yeah okay so just making sure
people know that's the case that can
encourage people to share or open up or
whatever
okay yeah because i mean we've got uh
people in the office and it's it's
constant and and you can he you can
you can tend to see the people that go a
little bit quiet or
you know every everyone's got got things
on but you know you can you kind of
notice things um and um yeah
it's just a a quick message just to see
how they're doing and
um yeah just yeah i think i think it's
just
i think that's all was really important
to do that they don't feel on their own
i think especially since you know the
the the the lockdown and
people on their own and feeling a little
bit isolated then um
very much a supportive bunch of people i
would say
nice so what i um wanted to just ask you
a couple of things now
vicky is like your sort of journey with
client and business development real
popular area that people want sort of
advice and
and people to share their their journey
with so i guess
like what what was your biggest
challenge with client development early
on would you say
um i think initially it was just getting
on the phone it was
um it was putting the call in um i i
remember as well
perhaps being a little bit reluctant to
talk to directors
or managing directors and somebody said
you know they put their knickers on
exactly the same way as you do
you know they should be no different and
now my area is just focusing purely on
leadership and senior level appointments
and i
you know i i love it when i can speak to
it to
a client at that level because i know
it'll have a knock-on effect with
everybody else as well
um so i think just initially the the uh
the butterflies in the stomach about
picking up the phone and making those
sales calls initially
um but that's that's the job and and
there's no getting away from it and
um the the uh the work that you do
with regards to a good sales call
there's no better feeling i
you know i love when it winning a client
round and uh
there's been many instances where
they've not been particularly nice
initially
you keep going with it you keep um being
visible in their space you
keep keep at it and then they say you
know
yeah let's let's have a conversation
it's
it's great for me so yeah so yeah i
think that's a
quite common one i'm i was definitely
guilty of that of putting clients on the
pedestal
and it is the typical advice right um
yeah they put you
put your knickers on the same as you do
or whatever but it's it's just really
remembering that they are human and um
yeah
go find them on facebook or instagram
you'll find that they're they're just
people like yeah like you are um so i
guess
what um you're talking about it there
like what um people are always
interested to hear like how
what's been the most effective way vicky
has managed to get the first meeting
with clients you're looking to open up
or start building relationships with
what's been the most effective way that
you've been able to get that first
meeting with with
target clients um yeah so it's it's
it's all about the impact and the
engagement that you have and that trust
that they but you can build up
and that's that comes with time
and then by talking about the importance
as to why
um they need to meet you um and and
explaining
those then then that's when they get it
um and that's when they think oh they
vicki's taking this seriously you know
she really wants to to to make sure that
we've we you know we find the right
person
and and it's very much a way and i
wanted you know us to work together as a
team
um for me meetings um i know we spoke
about this before but
there's such an important part of the
recruitment process and and again one of
my favorite things is that
you know you get that break away from
the office you really on earth that the
issues that that person's got
um or other that the business has or
the type of person that they are looking
for it's just such an important part of
of the whole
recruitment process whether they've got
a job or not you've got to be getting to
know that
those businesses to that degree um
so yeah to to get them it's it's just
constant contact with them getting
getting their engagement
and that's been visible definitely in
their space for sure
what do you think is the most important
thing that like what when you think
about right i've got a now this first
meeting
what do you think makes it a successful
meeting
uh preparation without a doubt um
looking at
um what the business does looking at the
their linkedin profile
preparing what you want to be talking
about and very much going in from the
very beginning that it's your meeting
you take control of that meeting from
the moment that you you you step through
the door
um you know you're taking time out of
your day not doing the the business
development this has to make sure that
you you know you get
you're getting some um something on the
back of it so um
it's it's making sure you go in with
that confidence that this is your
meeting
and this and this is going to be the
agenda so it's it's definitely about
preparation for me
yeah and um would you say you've i know
you should
probably always prepare but like the
good thing about if you really prepare
is then
you do build up a bit of a script right
or you build up like
a bit of a system of doing it i remember
that that really helped me
how get more out of the client meetings
and actually it was as simple as
preparing or really knowing what
the agenda was right and actually when
you have that initial moment sit down
speak to them blah blah blah and then
you go
right so um look i haven't gotten a
formal agenda together but this is what
i wanted to achieve of our time together
and actually really break it down and
set
the tone and when you do that it
actually
helps you remember what you need to
cover and those types of things that
that's interesting that
you shared that so i guess um the other
thing that
i wanted to ask you um around this was
how have you had to how have you
approached business development over the
the recent period because because it
seems like that's been a real common
challenge for recruiters like what if
you're just keep
if you keep getting vicky we're doing
this direct victory we're not hiring at
the moment like
what i don't know what how have you sort
of made sure that you stay in front of
mind
engaging these people providing value
what what have you been doing over the
last six to eight months that
people could sort of benefit from that
listening to this that might be
struggling
um well what what i've really liked to
do is
um by using video technology so um we
use our draw so it's very much
um not just the emails that may get lost
in other messages but it's sending those
video messages through linkedin or
through email but they actually get to
see that picture um
and uh by offering something that's that
maybe is a little bit different that
a little bit eye-catching um business
development is all about
um at the moment um
you know how are you finding things um
you know it might not be that they're
recruiting right now although
this second lockdown seems to be that
people have a little bit more confidence
they've been through it before where
they literally
came to a screeching halt in march uh
whereas now things seem to be ticking
along
in the background quite nicely still
touch wood um
um so yeah it's all about just making
sure that that
that we're touching base that contact is
still very much there
um you know we're here to support them
for what they need
uh whether that's somebody on a
short-term basis if it's just a you know
they don't want to take anybody on a
permanent basis but it's just a contract
or um you know in terms of the volumes
of applications
you know it's taken us too long can you
can you recommend two or three good
people so just
really asking questions around their
situation how they're finding it
but also then being able to be there as
a support for
for um any vacancies that that they seem
to have at
the time and then just a real real
practical one here and it's something
that's ended up in my inbox a couple of
times what's
what's like vicky's go-to sort of
objection
handle around the typical sorry vicky
we've got a psl yeah um
psl god those three little letters
it's um it's actually something that's
been brought up in a lot of
role plays that we do or um
sort of training situations and i've had
various different
um comebacks on the back of that what i
particularly like
is that you know this business has taken
recruitment seriously but
by having a psl um and that you work
actually
with a lot of companies that that um
that are outside that psl you work you
know you work and give them the best
talent because you find that recruiters
who are on these lists then are they
getting a bit too complex and are they
getting the best talent that's out there
are they working as hard as they should
be
um so it's love that you've got a psl
i love that you've taken the recruitment
quite seriously um
and this is and this is how i work sort
of thing so yeah the various different
objection handlings for that but that's
one i i really like
okay interesting um so look
i'd love to do sort of breakdown um
things around
um why vicky managed to to achieve
top biller status at theo james what
what
what um what's been your what's been
your best year at theo james
billings wise yes it was before yeah so
um
this is our um so in year five it was my
third year
and i've always increased uh improved my
balencia one year i always try
try to do that my role changed that i
was focusing on leadership
and senior level appointments as opposed
to um the supply chain arena so it was
changing slightly and it was just
getting momentum and then march came
and literally as i said everything came
with screeching hope my pipeline
looked really really healthy so it was
really frustrating um so these are
operations managers um commercial
managers up to direct to level roles so
um we were starting to get some real
headway there was it was it was going
really well and then um
as i said in march came to screeching
hall everyone came home and
and and actually i secured um a real
good contract with the business that
were making parts for ventilators
so their orders just went through the
reef which was great
and then um so we did all of their
permanent recruitment so that
i was having to to go back into to
recruit for roles outside of leadership
and it was you just gotta get them
filled i've got we've got people on
furlough here
um i really i was it was in the the
spare room in
in in the house and i had the door shut
and it was just i've just got a crack on
so
every single job came in i was just
filling i was just making sure i was
getting them filled
um so it was it was a great end to
what's been
just such a really rubbish year
um so there was a target of of winning a
bmw i8 for a weekend
uh i managed to get that for the best
quarter uh
i want a holiday to vegas because i got
top villa so it's been
great it's been really really good um
but for me
it was head down just got to get these
jobs filled we've got to make hay
while the sun shines so yeah and this is
a great contract for us
um uh yeah we and and and just worked
really
bloody hard to try and get these jobs
filled so it's uh
it was finished um
well i mean the fees were a lot lower um
because of the rules so it was about 145
i finished on
um but yeah it was uh it went a lot
better than what it could have done when
i sat in march i was really panicking
it seems to have continued on which is
which is good
um getting back into those leadership
roles everyone's now one
they're not they're not furloughed which
is great but um
yeah it was a busy time it's been a
difficult difficult
yeah right i guess just a quick question
around because you said like you've
always
increased your billings or pushed on
right i guess
how how have you continued to how have
you continued to motivate yourself to
break your own records
yeah i always look at um
probably again the last four years being
an advocate of
reflecting and reviewing those and
making a plan of action for for the next
year or next quarter
it that that's been really key for me so
um one
one occasion i looked at right what was
my average billing
um what was my average fee right well i
want to increase that for next year
um we've made a i think we've made a
real conscious effort in terms of
increasing the percentages that we're
charging and that's something i'm a
massive advocate of
um you know we're not working at these
reduced fees um we're sticking by our
guns
we do a good job and we work really hard
and this is what we're going to be doing
and and and training people where we
stop at conversation you know
the fee is going to be this stop the
conversation don't start getting into
the negotiation until you have to
so i think so many people think oh well
this client's working with this
this other agency for 12 and i want to
be working with them
well well no stick buy your guns you've
got a good you know you're good at what
you do
they will come back round because if
that you know if they they're happy to
work with those discounted fees
then they may get a discounted service
so um really
standing up for your terms and um i'm
not just rolling over the first
at the first time so that's a huge
success for me
so so so the part that's motivated you
then is just
i guess reflecting on there is a that
can
yeah again increase your billings but
you're
slightly gaining marginal gains if
that's the increasing average fee or
whatever
and actually the end that okay that's
interesting and
and i think as well um we've done a lot
more focus
and and i have um in getting those
returned assignments
um that that's been a big game changer
for me
getting those a grade jobs where they
are exclusive you've got a commitment
fee up front so you're not working for
free
again that's something that we we're
doing i'm doing a lot more of and as a
company
we need to be doing more of and that
that we just want to continue on doing
so okay interesting quick one on that
then
what was the biggest obstacle barrier
you had to
get over yourself to go because a lot of
people think what's the difference
between contingent and retained
and these things so i guess what were
the biggest barriers that you had to get
yourself over to
be more successful at closing those
retained assignments
first of all knowing your product that
was uh yeah you've got it you've got to
know what your offerings are and what
what
um what the solutions are so um you know
finding those pains out
ultimately asking the question we just
weren't asking i i wasn't asking the
question
uh you know going along with this
contingency way of recruiting um
is is is all well and good but you know
to get those
retained assignments where they they're
real great jobs it's almost a guaranteed
fee in in your pipeline i love being
able to forecast
and you know accurately and being
accountable for my figures and my
pipeline
so to be able to do that um a lot more
accurately by getting these jobs was
was just critical so you know it's it's
just um
getting over that because it isn't easy
you know you've got to understand
that i think the method behind us but
but at the same time you can overthink
it
it's not difficult the process should be
exactly the same
but just a lot more concentrated than
the clients going to get a much better
service
so it's just it's just yeah it's just
just actually making the time to think
about
yeah what your product is the the
problems that you're solving and then
and then actually asking the question
and
and explaining why um
so something that people always want to
hear about vicky is like how
how has vicky's sort of daily routine
and how you sort
of how you structure your day change
from like early on
um to to now right because i'm sure
you've you've got that nailed down and
you've got non-negotiables like tell us
about what a typical
day looks like for vicki and how you
structure your day that you feel was
giving you the best possible chance of
maximizing each day
the the the big change for me was we had
trevor pinder
um come into our uh into our office for
a couple of days training which was
great fun
and he told us about the ivy league so
it's preparing
um five or six things the night before
in terms of what you want to achieve
and by writing that down um
makes you accountable it's in your mind
as to what you're going to be attacking
that day
there's no worse thing you sat at your
desk and you don't know
your plan who you're going to be selling
to that day
um you know what jobs are you going to
be looking at so
um to do that the night before and it
sort of gets your mind thinking if you
can prepare those lists as well
previously it's it's a real game changer
i i think
um that that preparation um
yeah it just gets the mindset ready so
when you start the next day
but preparing the day before and then
what so break your day
down a bit then to life so you pray that
you prepared your day before that's
super key
and you know what you need to focus on
and what you're attacking the following
day
where what so you said like what a 8 30
you checking with the team
and then what the rest should they look
like yeah it's a it's
a check-in uh make sure that they're set
for the day find out what their
objectives are
um 8 30 till 10 i'll be speaking to new
candidates or
people that have applied for jobs um
i'll also during those conversations not
only ask for leads but
ask them to talk to me about who their
best manager is
for recommendations and then 10 or 12
i'll be doing business development
12 till uh two um again i'm catching up
with the team to make sure that they
are they've achieved part of what they
need to do
or if they need any steer in terms of
what the afternoon's going to uh
going to involve um and then the staff
then in the afternoon
a bit more business development and then
some job management so
if it's i've got interviews um that i'm
i've arranged where i'm meeting with
candidates online
um or i've got meetings with clients um
so yeah business development with with
some job management as well
um i i work till i work reduce out so
far
and and have done um since my second
daughter was born so she's 13 now
um so but i'm constantly doing bits and
pieces
at home as well which which um is is
just
part of what i do um so yeah i'll i'll
i'll work
i'll work to those hours i love that and
then
just quick one on this vicky what's come
up a lot when
um we've had um women on this show is
like this sort of
sort of dilemma that people can find
themselves in where you have to
you come to a bit of a crossroads where
sort of vicky
has to maybe decide around putting her
career first or her
family first right it's come up a lot as
to whenever
we've had people on this podcast and
talking about why
there is a lack of female role models or
lack of female leaders in recruitment
businesses
and typically whenever we've had these
conversations it has
um led to well i was thinking about
starting a family and i was really
worried that that would just
put my career on ice basically and i'd
never be able to take it to where it was
so you're just talking about there where
yeah you've had two children
obviously you had first child at the
beginning of your recruitment career so
i guess
like how how have you made sure that um
i don't know what's helped you make sure
that your career stayed
pushing forward as well as being a mom
and raising two children
yeah um really interesting actually um
i always knew that i wanted i'm one of
four uh i always wanted
two kids uh took a while so uh to
for us to decide i'm quite indecisive
just make a decision um so georgia was
was seven
uh and then chloe came along in 2007 so
i returned back to work when the economy
crashed
it was just the worst time uh
i thought i'd lost it i thought i
thought i've
i've absolutely lost the knack of how to
do this
um many many tears um
and at the time i really really
respect um my director who just that
get that that that tenacious attitude
where we've got to battle through
we've got to carry on here and what you
know
share information there was meetings
early on who were you working with are
you talking to them
you know they were they were um scary
moments um there was redundancies
happening in the office i hadn't been
um in an environment where that had
happened before
um and actually again i had a fantastic
year i think
over 200 000 that year and we
diversified i did temporary and
permanent recruitment
because we just had to be that agile we
just had to whatever the client needed
support was we just had to just get on
and do
um but yeah it was it was scary to
initially i thought
that you know i i love this job and i
feel like that time i
had nine months off and i um
i couldn't have come back bless you
what would your advice be like because
we
a lot of people talk about work-life
balance right and stuff and that's
something that it seems like you you've
really
um achieved it sounds like uh but like i
don't know what and i'm sure you have
good
better days of it and worser days but
like what's really helped you
make sure that vicky uh the mother
hasn't missed those moments and you have
um still kept your career on track and
you've achieved that work-life balance i
don't know if there's anything you can
share there that
other people could maybe take away that
can really help them achieve more
work-life balance
yeah um to begin with it was um
it was a tough one it was a tough one to
not just get
get my head around as i said my two very
good friends were
that was the way that they were working
so i kind of expected to be doing it
um my husband's worked for nissan for 30
years so
he's clocked on he's clocked off and
that's it that's him done
so um you know changing mindset not only
for me but also in the in the family
home to say
i just need to do this i want to
but it's i i just need to do it i can't
let i can't leave this until the next
day
so there's definitely been instances
where we've done that and and obviously
now through the years it's just part and
parcel of what i do
um i'll never forget i was driving in
the car and i was taking some interview
feedback and i was taking georgia to
dancing or something and uh
it was great and i was able to offer the
the job over the phone and
and uh jordan was very little at the
time and she was just walking around you
got the job
copying what what i said and that's a
proud moment for me
and she doesn't want to be in
recruitment
but yeah they've kind of grown up with
this is this is what i do
i don't let it impact my my um time with
them
um ever too much i always make a
conscious effort that
i do what i need to do and then that's
it um
mark uh made a really good point that he
he turns his phone off at six that's a
non-negotiable for him and
you know just putting my phone in the
draw for a saturday uh
for a couple of hours i i really like um
you know i've actually come off
so other social media and spent more
time on if i'm going to check anything
i'll i might
flick through linkedin or um you know
just make sure that it's worth my while
and and that's been
that's been really good for me um if
you're watching tell you on the night
time
my phones are weird i'm not on it all
the time and and
and just really being disciplined with
that is is really important
yeah that's awesome well um look vic
i've got five
questions for you to end this all right
and uh yeah and then we'll i'm not real
blonde
[Laughter]
so it's the first question i have for
you um is
um if you could change the industry what
would you improve
i would really like to change people's
mindset on what a recruiter does i
really get frustrated when we get um
i was on holiday and when i happened to
mention what i did and
i like the distaste the the distasteful
look on on his face i've really
i'm i'm proud of what i do and i love
what i do and
i was really really upset by that so
that mindset but also the mindset of
people
entering into recruitment that oh you
know it's it's
uh you know it might be tough but you
can make lots of money
it's actually really hard and you need
to have a really winning mindset there's
so many things that you need to have to
be a good recruiter
um so turning people's mindset in terms
of what we're about i would say would be
the big thing that i would like to
change
i love that um so next question is
uh what what book have you read that has
had the biggest impact on you
and if you don't read you can substitute
that for a podcast
audio book or whatever but what what's
what have you read or sort of in
in your sort of um yeah what's had the
biggest impact on you
yeah i love this question because that's
something i probably couldn't answer
three years ago
um i've i've really constantly i've
really
made an effort in in reading more um
books around
business um as well as actually other
books as well
um but for me what had the biggest
impact was
sumo so it stands for shut up and move
on
um which is it which is such a good book
we now actually make everybody read it
when they come into the business
so allowing yourself that hippo time
when something doesn't go well
you can have that hip or time where you
know you you're fed up or
you you know you're down in the dumps
but then you shut up and you move on and
you use that energy and you just crack
on so that
that for me had the biggest impact i
love that book i love that show
so what is it called sumo see more
like that i haven't heard of that that's
my accent it's sumo
s-u-m all oh okay
okay okay great so next question
um so if vicky could write a linkedin
post that could be seen by
every single recruitment consultant
across the world
what would you want it to say
about recruitment whatev like if every
recruitment consultant would see it
what would you want to say it could be
anything um
probably a post that i did quite
recently and again going back to what
the advice that i give is be your own
biggest cheerleader
don't beat yourself up you're good
you've got a lot of to offer
you're good at what you do and just go
for it
smile and just go for it i like it
what what did you spend your first
biggest
commission paycheck on
um this is going to make me sound really
materialistic but
i do like a louis vuitton bag i do i
love them
i'm not gonna lie louis vuitton bag
yeah lovely last question
what what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
my goal would be um that i get to it
to be a director that that is the end
goal for me
and it's insight and i will work and
i'll get it and i'll achieve it and i'll
work towards it
vicky it's been an absolute pleasure you
too thank you for having me